und damit kommen wir zuerst eine
rednerin in dieser debatte
kerstin radomski
kollegen
vor der verabschiedung des einzel plans
30 bildung und forschung blicken wir in
dieser debatte auf ganz zentrale
politikfelder für die zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres landes
dabei ist es unsere aufgabe
bild das bildungs und
wissenschaftssystem immer wieder aufs
neue zukunftsfest zu machen
es wird ein stabiles fundament gebraucht
von guter schulischer bildung und
beruflicher bildung vor ort bis hin zu
exzellenter wissenschaft die auch im
weltweiten vergleich vorne mitspielt
damit dies weiterhin gelingt haben sie
unter anderem die deutsche agentur für
transfer und innovation die daten ins
leben gerufen schon bei der einbringung
des haushalts haben wir als
unionsfraktion hier im plenum das fehlen
eines schlüssigen konzepts kritisiert
dass bei einer summe von 15 millionen
euro aus unserer sicht zwingend
notwendig ist
cdu und csu haben dann einen antrag für
eine sperre der da die haushaltsmittel
eingebracht die nur durch das parlament
aufgehoben werden kann wir freuen uns
dass die ampel koalition nach einer
ablehnung unseres antrags dann doch dazu
übergegangen ist einen eigenen antrag
einzubringen den wir natürlich dann
gerne in ähnlicher wort roy zugestimmt
haben
unsere zustimmung galt in den
haushaltsberatungen auch der sperre im
kontext der agentur für sprung
innovation der helmholtz gemeinschaft
und dem berliner institut für
gesundheitsforschung es ist gut dass wir
die kontrollfunktion des parlamentes
gegenüber der exekutive so selbstbewusst
betonen und das können wir natürlich am
besten alle gemeinsam
im bereich forschung empfinden wir es
aber natürlich als bedauerlich dass sie
unsere ideen zu drei aus unserer sicht
wichtigen wettbewerben nicht gefolgt
sind als ampelkoalition zum einen hatten
wir den start eines wettbewerbs neue
therapieansätze gegen
autoimmunerkrankungen
eingebracht in den ausschuss bei diesen
erkrankungen handelt es sich zum
beispiel um fehlsteuerung des
immunsystems vom typ 1 diabetes rheuma
da gibt es viele erkrankungen die davon
betroffen sind wir würden uns wünschen
wenn sie da sich verhalten wie bei der
partie und vielleicht in zukunft ein
unserer anträge übernehmen würden
außerdem haben sie den antrag abgelegt
für einen wettbewerb grüne
landwirtschaft innovative innovative
lebensmittelproduktion
angesichts der aktuellen lage in der
ukraine hätten wir es auch natürlich
hier gut gefunden wenn sie diesen
innovationen ansätzen gefolgt werden der
dritte antrag
handelte um
fusionstechnologie es geht dabei um
energieerzeugung mit kernfusion ich
denke dass es so ein wichtiges thema und
gerade die debatten die sich viel um
energieversorgung kranken da sollten wir
doch in zukunft alle gemeinsam darauf
achten dass gerade bei der
fusionstechnologie wir was machen die
ampel hat da in den haushaltsberatungen
etwas gestrichen aber ich glaube wenn
wir das gemeinsam uns nochmal genauer
angucken können wir da auch für die
zukunft einiges für unser land erreichen
blicken wir auf den bereich bildung wie
wichtig dieser ist zeigt dass ich in den
letzten tagen die veröffentlichte mint
frühjahrs report da geht es um die
schulische wissens wissensvermittlung in
mathematik informatik
naturwissenschaften und technik doch
nicht nur im mittenbereich gibt es
defizite auch das handwerk schlägt alarm
in deutschland da es an fachkräften
mangelt und ausbildungsberufe besser
durch gefördert werden müssen sehr
bedauerlich finden wir deshalb die
kürzung bei der beruflichen bildung denn
wir sehen es als enorm wichtig an die
fachkräfte für unser land zu haben
es ist auch ein falsches signal
denn diese fachkräfte gefährden viele
projekte der ampelkoalition denn wenn
die fachkräfte im handwerk fehlen dann
sind die großen angekündigten vorhaben
nicht umsetzbar wie energiewende
wohnungsbau und viele andere projekte
wissenschaftler sind wichtig und es ist
auch wichtig dass wir politiker haben
aber ohne fachkräfte bauen wir keine
häuser und werden wir auch die
energetische sanierung der gebäude nicht
voranbringen
wir als unions fraktion würden uns
deshalb von ihnen wünschen und wir haben
dazu auch diverse anträge eingebracht
dass sie die bedeutung der dualen
ausbildung wieder auf das niveau heben
dass wir in unserem entwurf des des
haushaltes hatten im letzten jahr
dann bleibt mir noch ein thema das mir
als lehrerin sehr am herzen liegt die
alphabetisierung wir haben in diesem
bereich echten aufholbedarf in
deutschland jedes jahr investieren wir
als bund geld in alphabetisierung von
erwachsenen
ich glaube es tut allen gut wenn wir uns
nochmal die anträge zu unseren wünschen
zu gutachten zur alphabetisierung von
menschen in der schulischen ausbildung
anschauen weil es darf einfach nicht
sein dass kinder unser schulsystem
verlassen analphabeten zu sein
deshalb weil die fragen der
alphabetisierung kleider von ihnen
abgelehnt worden sind unsere anträge zur
beruflichen bildung abgelehnt worden
sind können wir den kurs der
koalitionsfraktionen nicht mitgehen und
werden ihren haushalt ablehnen
dankeschön
kerstin radomski aus der unionsfraktion
hat es angesprochen einige gelder hatte
haushaltsausschuss gesperrt unter
anderem für die deutsche agentur für
transfer und innovation und die
bundesagentur für sprung innovation da
werden allerdings einfach weitere
konzepte verlangt dann wird die sperrung
wieder aufgehoben ist es also nicht so
gravierend wie zum beispiel eine kürzung
die dauerhaft wäre christoph meyer
spricht jetzt für die fdp fraktion
ist die grundlage für freie
selbstbestimmte menschen für
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt für
technologische souveränität und deswegen
bin ich froh dass es uns gelungen ist
trotz der schwierigen haushaltslage den
regierungsentwurf denen die große
koalition im letzten jahr noch vorgelegt
hat um über 100 millionen euro zu
steigern und das ist uns gelungen ist in
der mittelfristplanung ebenfalls weitere
mittel aufwüchse zu garantieren und zu
sichern
wir hatten das klang eben schon an sehr
konstruktive parlamentarische beratungen
es war die ampel koalition die hier die
besonderen dank aus wie gestern als
haupt berichterstatterin hier sehr
moderierend gewirkt hat ich möchte aber
auch ausdrücklich loben dass die cdu csu
in diesem einzelplan in diesen bereichen
anders als in anderen bereichen sehr
fleißig änderungsanträge und
initiativen ergriffen hat das ist
offensichtlich noch nicht
selbstverständlich deswegen sollte sich
der eine oder andere vielleicht an
kerstin radomski ein beispiel nehmen
investitionen
investitionen die wir in den
parlamentarischen beratungen noch
angeschoben haben gegen den bereich
digitalisierung
leistungsfähigkeit des bildungswesens
nachwuchsförderung wettbewerbsfähigkeit
des wissenschafts und innovationssystems
ich freue mich besonders dass hier im
bereich der bioökonomie auf höchster
erzielen konnten gerade im bereich von
nahrungsmittel forschung
nahrungsmittelknappheit ist schon
angesprochen worden haben wir unsere
eigene akzente gesetzt wir sind im
bereich der post co at long cupid
forschung ein stück weiter gegangen und
auch im bereich der mentalen gesundheit
und was hier formuliert wurde zum thema
kernfusion kann ich so nicht stehen
lassen wir haben natürlich mit iter
projekt was nicht direkt aus dem
nationalen etat finanziert wird sondern
über die europäische ebene aber dennoch
ist deutschland hier natürlich mittelbar
beteiligt und das wird natürlich eine
der schlüsseltechnologien sein auf die
wir in zukunft setzen müssen
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage des
kollegen jarzombek
sie sind doch selbst noch drei oder wir
können also dann weiter in der rede
genauso
wie einen klaren fokus für junge
menschen in diesem etat wir haben auf
neue technologien gesetzt und wir haben
das auch schon angesprochen neue
konzepte von transfer wissenschaft in
anwendung hier mit der daten mit anderen
projekten und ich finde es eine frage
der souveränität des parlamentes dass
man hier mit dem ministerium zusammen
entsprechend auch aus satirische vermerk
anbringt die eine sperre und deswegen
werden wir uns die entsprechenden
projekte angucken und dann sicherlich
auch zügig da bin ich überzeugt so eine
entsperrung kommen uns ist es gelungen
die polarstern zwei zu finanzieren auch
ein thema was die vorgängerin der
ministerin nicht geschafft hat so dass
wir alles in allen
ein
konkreter beschluss einen guten
haushaltsentwurf noch besser gemacht
haben und deswegen werden wir mit freude
zu stimmen und freuen uns auf den
haushalt 2023 dank
christoph meyer weil man sich für die
fdp nächster redner ist für die
fdp-fraktion götz frömming
[Applaus]
sehr
geehrte damen und herren in einer rede
am 29 november 2008 10 habe ich hier an
dieser stelle prophezeit dass der
digital packt scheitern wird damals
haben sie gelacht und sind über unsere
wohl begründeten bedenken hinweg
gegangen nun erhalten wir die erste
evolution in form eines berichtes des
bundesrechnungshofs von diesem jahr und
meine damen und herren dieses
zwischenzeugnis dass sie hier alle
miteinander erhalten fällt für sie
verheerend aus der bundesrechnungshof
stellt fest dass fehler den bund nicht
nur an der zuständigkeit sondern
vielmehr führten seine initiativen zu
angeboten die redundanz zu denen der
länder sein sie sind damit
unwirtschaftlich es drohten weiterhin so
wörtlich förder ruinen für deren
weiterbetrieb es keine perspektive gibt
das meine damen und herren ist das
ergebnis ihrer verfehlten
haushaltspolitik
das was wir hier über den digital packt
gesagt haben das könnte als drohendes
motto über ihren gesamten haushalt
stehen deutschland als förderung für
deren weiterbetrieb es keine perspektive
mehr gibt man muss aufgrund früherer
äußerungen insbesondere aus den reihen
der grünen ja fast annehmen dass einige
von ihnen diesen untergang heimlich
herbei singen meine damen und herren
dass wir uns nicht missverstehen eine
vernünftige internetanbindung in den
schulen oder ein warmes mittagessen das
sind wichtige dinge das befürworten auch
wir aber das sind auch
selbstverständlichkeit meine damen und
herren und sicherlich könnten die länder
und die kommunen besser dafür sorgen als
wenn wir das hier von berlin aus fuhren
meine damen und herren da wo sie
wirklich als bundesgesetzgeber gefragt
sind das scheitern sie für die
berufliche bildung tun sie nach wie vor
viel zu wenig beziehungsweise das
falsche auch hier beklagt der
bundesrechnungshof zu recht eine
fehlende gesetzliche grundlage und einen
koordinierten förderdschungel in dem
sich keiner mehr auskenne das gleiche
übrigens jetzt erleben wir beim bafög
haben sie einen neuen entwurf vorgelegt
über den werden wir noch reden müssen
auch hier ein vernichtendes zeugnis vom
bundesrechnungshof auf 40 seiten man
damen und herren man muss auch fragen
warum der bund meint ständig mit
projekten bzw in projekte zu finanzieren
wie ich nenne nur mal beispielhaft
demokratie leben kultur macht stark
bildung für nachhaltige entwicklung das
sind alles so tolle wohlklingenden namen
aber warum tun sie das als bunt sind da
nicht eigentlich die länder für
zuständig und trauen sie an der stelle
trauen sie an der stelle nicht den
lehrern vor ort zu das richtige zu tun
wir stellen fest dass es um unsere
bildungseinrichtungen herum herr gehring
inzwischen einen regelrechten sumpf von
externen bildungsanbietern gibt
ebenso wenig übrigens wie auf diesen
bildungs sumpf an externen
bildungsanbietern lehrer und schüler
gewartet haben ebenso wenig haben sie
übrigens auf das erwartet was uns
tagtäglich im früher so genannten
bildungsfernsehen erwartet lesen sie mal
die berichte vom heutigen tage das ist
eher eine perverse gender ideologie die
hier verbreitet wird statt
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
meine damen und herren
sie ihren die seit jahren zu
beobachtende schleichende umwandlung des
einzigen atom und forschungsministeriums
zu einem ministerium dass man
ministerium für bildung und umerziehung
nennen könnte schuld daran ist
maßgeblich der einfluss der grünen und
ihre außerparlamentarischen
vorfeldorganisationen frau ministerin
sie sind ja von der fdp sie stehen hier
in der verantwortung trocknen sie diesen
grünen sumpf aus befreien sie ihr
ministerium aus der geiselhaft der
grünen meine damen und herren
deutschland droht parallel dazu den
anschluss an internationale
spitzenforschung zu verlieren das sehen
wir im bereich der künstlichen
intelligenz china usa haben uns längst
abgehängt wir sehen es aber auch in
anderen bereichen kernenergie ist schon
genannt worden die haben sich von einem
kompletten forschungszweig verabschiedet
übrigens auch ein deutscher sonderweg
das ist nie eine gute idee meine damen
und herren vielleicht erleben wir aber
von den grünen einen weiteren purzelbaum
denn sie haben sich ja entschieden
waffen in kriegsgebiete zu liefern und
nehmen kauf einer autobahn kommen sie
mit dem studieren vielleicht trauen sich
dann ja auch in die kernenergie
forschung wieder einzusteigen vielen
dank
chris fleming war das von der
fdp-fraktion auf in ihren vierteln
briefkästen
sie ist berichterstatterin für den
einzelplan 30 für die spd
frau präsidentin werte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir lesen
in dieser stunde den einzelplan 30 also
den haushalt des bildungsministeriums
und forschungsministeriums und die gute
nachricht hatten wir in der ersten
lesung bereits der plafond also die
mittel die zur verfügung stehen für
bildung und forschung in den nächsten
jahren wird steigen und wir können heute
in der zweiten und dritten lesung sagen
es gibt eine noch bessere nachricht denn
diese steigerung nach der
bereinigungssitzung fällt noch höher aus
insgesamt werden in den nächsten jahren
rund vier milliarden euro mehr zur
verfügung haben das zeigt wie wichtig
uns bildung und forschung sind ich
möchte ein paar sachen high leiten die
wir jetzt im parlamentarischen verfahren
den letzten wochen noch geändert haben
schule die bildungsgerechtigkeit ist uns
wichtig und darum haben wir mit einem
maßgabe beschluss sichergestellt dass
das startchancen programm das 4000
schulen in besonders schwierigen
räumlichen
gesellschaftlichen lagen steht dass wir
4000 schulen zusätzlich fördern wir
schaffen mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit wir
nehmen die silbernen skoda aber auch in
dem weg weil uns schülerinnen und
schüler und auch ihre vor allem ihre
demokratisch gewählte
interessensvertretung wichtig ist und
darum haben wir beschlossen nachdem sie
jahrelang gefordert haben das haus sich
immer gesperrt hat und wir jetzt im
parlamentarischen verfahren durchsetzen
konnten dass sie einen eigenen etat und
eine eigene geschäftsstelle bekommen und
das ist so wichtig weil das bedeutet
dass sie sich weniger mit
organisatorischen kram beschäftigen
müssen sondern ganz auf die inhaltliche
arbeit konzentrieren können und auch
wenn das manchmal unbequem für uns als
politikerinnen und politikern wird so
wenn wir die jungen menschen doch ernst
nehmen und darum war das gut dass wir
das beschlossen
wir stärken die ausbildung die
überbetrieblichen ausbildungsstätten
stärker als ursprünglich veranschlagt
mit zwei millionen euro mehr das ist ein
wichtiger beitrag dazu dass wir wenn uns
die gesellschaftliche transformation zu
einer klimafreundlichen klimaneutralen
krisen resilienz gesellschaft wirtschaft
gelingen will dann brauchen wir deutlich
dass praktisch umsetzen darum mehr
mithilfe überbetrieblicher
ausbildungsstätten
im bereich studium und hochschule
bekommen wir zwölf millionen euro mehr
für die stiftung innovation in der
hochschule das ist die nachfolge
stiftung nach dem qualitätspakt lehre
und wir bringen da zum ausdruck dass uns
die lehre an den hochschulen die auch
durch corona in den letzten jahren so
gefordert war wichtig ist dass wir als
bund die fördern wollen wir haben die
stiftung die noch recht jung ist sehr
ambitioniert an den start brachten viel
sagen wer mit parlamentarischen
verfahren eine kleine kurskorrektur
vorgenommen sind weil die mittel gekürzt
werden sollten wir jetzt aber das klare
signal können insbesondere die
begutachteten projekte im der freiraum
förderlinie können rechtzeitig an den
start gehen
die größte änderung aber im bereich
hochschulen wird die jährliche
dynamisierung des zukunftsvertrag
studium und lehre sein und da haben wir
uns auf einen maßgabe beschluss in der
bereinigungssitzung geeinigt der sagt
dass diese dynamisierung die von den
hochschulen lange gefordert war 20 23
jetzt an den start geht damit bekommen
die hochschulen noch mehr
planungssicherheit wir haben in der
großen koalition ist dafür eingesetzt
dass es steigerung stufen gibt jetzt
gibt es wirklich planungssicherheit mit
einer jährlichen dynamisierung und damit
will ich sagen gibt es so viel
planungssicherheit und hat der bund
seine hausaufgaben gemacht dass sich an
dieser stelle auch die erwartungshaltung
formulieren möchte mit diesem jahr die
steigenden mittel und den dauer aufgaben
die in der lehre an fallen denn das geld
ist ja ursprünglich über den
hochschulpakt gekommen weil es steigende
studierendenzahlen den muss gelten dauer
stellen für daueraufgaben wir werden die
evolution des wissenschafts zeitvertrag
gesetzt in den nächsten monaten hier auf
diskutieren und die verbesserung der
arbeitsbedingungen und auch vor allem
die westen karriere perspektiven für
junge wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wird uns nur gelingen
wenn alle drei bund länder und
hochschulen an einem strang ziehen und
meine klare erwartungshaltung meine
aufforderung an die hochschulen mit
diesem planungs sicheren mehr geld
setzte sich das sinnvoll ein
komm zur forschung auch hier haben wir
noch mal ordentlich drauf gesattelt 5
millionen für netzwerkarbeit und studien
im bereich
mcf syndrom kollege christoph meyer hat
es bereits an stellen dass die sache die
mir sehr am herzen liegt weil ich vor
einigen jahren im wahlkreis 1 dieser
gespräche hatte das eigentlich aus dem
kopf geht da hat eine familie mir
geschildert wie es ist wenn man
betroffen ist von dem chronischen fertig
syndrom beide sind erkrankt und ich
konnte es kaum glauben dass das eine der
langen eine der großen volkskrankheiten
ist zu denen es noch keine ausreichende
forschung gibt so gut wie gar keine
forschung 5 millionen euro mehr auch
durch den starken einsatz von stefan
schwartze als patientenbeauftragter der
bundesregierung können wir da jetzt
forschung ermöglichen und im übrigen ist
dieses chronische fertig symbol zuletzt
in breitere öffentlichkeit gewesen weil
ganz viele der longo wird patienten etwa
die hälfte derjenigen die an auch robert
erkrankt haben die charakteristischen
symptome von diesem chronisch fertig
symptome aufweisen das lieben wir
forschung an ein anderer bereich in der
forschung bei dem wir bereits exzellent
aufgestellt sind da sind wir in der
weltspitze der forschung ist die
polarstern 2 die klimaforschung und ist
seit jahren eine einheit darüber dass
die polarstern 2 drauf
aber weder im etat von kautschuk noch in
dem jetzt eingebrachten haushaltsentwurf
waren die mittel dafür italien es gab
bisher kein geld dafür und darum bin ich
sehr froh dass uns gemeinsam als ampel
gelungen ist dass wir in diesem jahr das
geld bereitstellen für die ausschreibung
und dass wir für die folgenden jahren
900 millionen euro zusätzlich für den
etat des bmbf für die polarstern zwei
die jetzt an den start gehen kann
beschafft haben und beschlossen haben
freut mich sehr
jetzt will ich mit blick auf die
nächsten monate und jahre sagen dass ich
mich sehr darauf freuen dass wir es
davon bin ich überzeugt schaffen dass es
uns gelingen wird dass wir auf neu
erfolgreich systeme auf setzen dass wir
über kommende strukturen anschieben wir
sind noch am anfang der legislatur aber
ich kann sagen wir werden endlich wir
haben das als spd schon lange gefordert
dass die forschung an fachhochschulen
gestärkt wird dass wir endlich mit der
deutschen agentur für transfer und
innovation dahin kommen die transfer
forschung in deutschland besser zu
fördern es liegt ein grobkonzept vor und
wir haben jetzt in den letzten wochen
die haushalterische sprache die es gab
weil eben erst das grobkonzept vorliegt
und weil uns das projekt so wichtig ist
und weil es so groß werden soll aus dem
raum des ministeriellen aus dem
finanzministerium rüber in den
parlamentarischen raum geholt um da auch
noch mal stärker mitgestalten zu können
und ich will an dieser stelle auch herr
sattelberger wenn sie jetzt heute nicht
mehr dabei sind mich noch einmal
bedanken für die sehr konstruktiven und
auch sehr innovativen diskussionen die
wir in den koalitionsverhandlungen dazu
geschafft haben das ist die grundlage
für die daten das wird bleiben damals
dafür meinen herzlichen dank
mit der grenzöffnung
mit der stromrichter sprint ballack uns
noch kein freiheits gesetz vor darum
haben wir gesagt wir müssen ein teil der
mittel sperren in den letzten tagen hat
uns der entwurf des gesetzes erreicht
ich freue mich auf die diskussion an der
stelle dann bin ich sicher wird auch das
ein großes und erfolgreiches projekt und
darum bleibt mir an dieser stelle zum
abschluss noch der dank und als erstes
weil mir das wichtig ist der dank an all
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
hintergrund die nicht heute abend hier
stehen die auch nicht in der presse
stehen aber ohne aldi das als
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
unseren abgeordneten büros in den
fraktionen aber auch im ministerium ohne
die das nicht möglich gewesen wäre dass
wir so gut und so konstruktiv aber auch
so gut informiert diskutiert haben einen
herzlichen dank an sie aber auch meinen
herzlichen dank an den scrum wird als
parlamentarischen staatssekretär an
judith fischer als verbeamteter
staatssekretär die die verantwortung für
den haushalt getragen haben und last but
not least den dank an meine kolleginnen
und kollegen christoph maier bode von
der koalition aber auch das konstruktive
gespräch mit kerstin radomski und petra
sitte ich freue mich sehr auf die
beratung für 20 23 danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
die paessler spd fraktion hat sich ja
auch noch nur weil thomas sattelberger
bedankt noch parlamentarische
staatssekretär im bildungsministerium
die aber schon angekündigt hat sich von
dem posten zurückzuziehen
kollegen der erste bildungshaushalt der
ampel koalition soll verabschiedet
werden und man kann resümieren soviel
große worte von fortschritt und von
chancen und dann soviel halbherzigkeit
und so wenig tatsächlicher aufbruch das
ist echt ein großes drama für die
bildung dabei hätten sie doch jetzt ganz
im sinne des caritas als koalition der
durchstarter und der macher ihre großen
ideen aus dem koalitionsvertrag auch
realität werden lassen können haben sie
aber nicht denn was passiert mit dem
etat für bildung und forschung die
geplanten ausgaben stagnieren und
gemessen an den tatsächlichen ausgaben
sinkt der haushalt sogar er singt und
sorge da reicht es auch nicht aus zu
behaupten dass er irgendwann dann mal
wieder ansteigen wird denn vertröstet
vertröstet werden die menschen jetzt
wirklich seit vielen jahren seit jahren
wird ihnen erklärt warum leider gerade
kein geld da ist für die soziale
infrastruktur für die öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge bloß von diesen
erklärungen können sich die menschen
natürlich nichts kaufen davon können
nicht mehr lehrkräfte eingestellt werden
davon lassen sich keine schul klos
sanieren dadurch werden nicht mehr
studierende aus der armut geholt und
davon entstehen eben auch nicht mehr
ausbildungsplätze und mit fortgesetzter
mangelwirtschaft lassen sich auch nicht
die miesen arbeitsbedingungen in der
wissenschaft beseitigen das ist die
wahrheit dass dies dann nicht mehr so
blumig und wohlklingend wie die rhetorik
der ampel aber dieser wahrheit muss sich
eben auch die ampel regierung stellen
frau ministerin in ihrer rede zur
einbringung des haushalts haben sie
gesagt wir machen tempo bei der bildung
damit wir rauskommen aus dem mittelmaß
frau ministerin welche definition von
tempo haben sie ihre großen vorhaben zum
beispiel startchancen programm kommen im
haushalt gar nicht vor die für 2022
sich vorgesehen die dynamisierung der
mittel für die hochschulen ist vertagt
ihre bafög-reform das ist ja einer der
wenigen posten die tatsächlich steigt in
diesem haushalt aber das verpufft weil
die inflation das plus komplett
auffrisst das bafög verbleibt unterhalb
des armutsrisikos für das programm zur
sicherung von ausbildungsstellen sie 375
millionen euro weniger bereit als noch
2021 ich meine 2,3 millionen junge
menschen zwischen 20 und 34 jahren haben
keine abgeschlossene berufsausbildung
diese junge menschen haben kaum chancen
auf gute und
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs kaum
chancen später mal nicht in der
altersarmut zu landen wo ist ihr konzept
diese jungen menschen in die ausbildung
zu bringen wo sehr konzept
die werbe parteien das was hier vorliegt
das ist einfach zu wenig schauen sie
sich die vorschläge der linken noch
einmal an wir wollen das bafög endlich
auf ein existenzsicherndes niveau
bringen und die verschuldung abschaffen
wir wollen eine gute soziale
infrastruktur für die hochschulen und
mehr geld für lehramts studienplätze und
wir wollen dass endlich mal investiert
wird in gute arbeitsbedingungen von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ich finde ich finde sie
müssen dringend anfangen prioritäten neu
und vor allem richtig zu setzen und im
übrigen es ist völlig inakzeptabel dass
kanzler und pendeln die ministerinnen
und minister dass energie geld bekommen
aber rentnerinnen und rentner und
studierende nicht vielen dank
nicole gohlke war das stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und sprecherin für
bildung und wissenschaft der
linksfraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag
nächste rednerin ist nun der sprecherin
für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung der grünen
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
ministerin liebe kolleginnen
die frau ministerin stark watzinger
spricht immer so gerne von ihrem
ministerium als dem scharfen ministerium
und muss ehrlich zugeben ich schmunzeln
immer so ein bisschen wenn die fdp dinge
neu benennt ja damit es besser klingt
damit man es besser verkaufen kann aber
an dieser stelle
an dieser stelle muss ich sagen die
ministerin hat recht dieses scheint sie
jetzt her zu bewegen wir bei der fdp
dass
trotz der ministerin recht eben an
dieser stelle
an dieser stelle hat sie recht dieses
ministerium ist das chancen ministerium
und dieser etat ist der etat der chancen
der chancen für die menschen in diesem
land
und
bei jeder cent den wir in die köpfe der
menschen stecken in bildung wissenschaft
und forschung sich am ende mehrfach
auszahlt ist dieses ministerium auch das
ministerium der chancen für unser land
denn das album geflügelte wort vom land
der dichter und denker das ist auch
heute übersetzt das land der
erneuerbaren energie und des corona im
stoff und das wollen wir bleiben und wir
wollen noch besser werden und dafür
legen wir mit diesem haushalt die
grundlage
und es ist dabei wichtig dass es egal
ist woher jemand kommt sondern nur zählt
wohin jemand will und deshalb
unterstützen wir vor allem da wo das
elternhaus das weniger kann und deswegen
haben wir im koalitionsvertrag das
startchancen programm festgeschrieben
damit werden wir schulen in
benachteiligten quartieren durch
zusätzliche schulsozialarbeit
unterstützen und ich freue mich sehr
dass wir mit dem maßgaben beschluss
dieses programm jetzt von fred
anschieben
und bündnisgrünen ist wichtig dass das
geld dann auch wirklich dort ankommt wo
es am dringendsten gebraucht wird und
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass das
ministerium dafür nun bis september 20
22 auch mögliche konzepte vorlegen wird
und natürlich ist auch die bafög-reform
werden ersten schritt wie er vor kurzem
hier bereits beschlossen haben ein
wichtiger baustein für mehr
chancengleichheit und auch hier haben
wir jetzt im haushalt entscheidende
weichen gestellt aber es ist auch klar
es wird eine herausforderung dass in den
kommenden jahr aus zu finanzieren und
darüber werden wir sicher noch sprechen
müssen
die chancengleichheit erreicht man aber
übrigens auch dann wenn alles ist
gleichermaßen beteiligen können und
deswegen freue ich mich sehr dass wir in
diesem haushalt 500.000 euro für die
bundesschülerkonferenz einstellen
konnten
als teil der bildungs engagement
strukturen ist sie ein wichtiger akteur
für mehr teilhabe und beteiligung und
gerade während der pandemie als kinder
und jugendliche viel zu wenig gehör
bekommen haben da hat die
bundesschülerkonferenz schüler in eine
stimme gegeben und dafür möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken
es ist
unsere aufgabe als politik das auf ernst
zu nehmen und sie mehr einzubinden und
das die bundesschülerkonferenz bereits
im bildungsausschuss eingeladen war das
zeigt dass wir diese aufgabe ernst
nehmen
was jetzt für beteiligungsstruktur im
haushalt angelegt ist ist ein guter
anfang ist aber auch wichtig dass wir
individuelle bedarf wenn diversen
engagement strukturen sorgfältig prüfen
und auch entsprechend unsere
vereinbarungen im koalitionsvertrag auf
weitere akteure in den kommenden jahren
unterstützen
aber ich habe eingangs gesagt es geht
bei diesem etat nicht nur um chancen für
die menschen sondern auch chancen für
unser land und zwar bei dieser idee eben
auch der etat für wissenschaft und
forschung ist und das ist unsere
wichtigste ressource
deshalb haben wir im koalitionsvertrag
die dynamisierung zukunftsvertrag
studium und lehre stärken beschlossen
das haben wir nun mit einem maßgaben
beschluss bestätigt und im jetzigen
haushalt bereits 12 millionen zusätzlich
für die stiftung innovation und
hochschullehrer eingestellt wir haben
sichergestellt dass das forschungsschiff
polarstern 2 kommt für die forschung und
insbesondere die klimaforschung ein
enorm wichtiges signal
im kampf gegen die klimakrise ist die
ist die forschung enorm wichtig aber im
kampf gegen die klimakrise brauchen wir
nicht nur forschung sondern müssen auch
in der bildung den kampf gegen den
klimawandel stärker verankern und
deshalb stärken wir die bildung für
nachhaltige entwicklung mit zusätzlichen
fünf millionen euro und verankern sie in
allen bildungsbereichen auch das ist ein
wichtiger beitrag im kampf gegen die
klimakrise und
gerade angesichts des kriegs in der
ukraine wissen wir wie wichtig der
internationale austausch von
studierenden und forschenden ist und wie
wichtig hier gerade solidarität ist
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass wir für
den dhb zusätzlich 13 8 millionen
bereitstellen konnten nun ist es gut
dass bis zu 67 4 millionen für die
öffnung des bafög für ukrainische
studierende und die verdopplung des
heizkostenzuschuss für bafög
empfängerinnen da sind wir bündnisgrüne
werden uns jedoch auch weiter dafür
einsetzen das bafög auch für schritt
tritt starterinnen zu öffnen und für uns
ist klar ist darf weder studierende noch
geflüchtet der erster und zweiter klasse
geben
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch in diesem
haushalt sind einige projekte angelegt
die in den kommenden jahr mit mehr geld
aus finanziert werden müssen wenn wir es
ernst meinen mit dem chancen ministerium
dann müssen wir auch in den kommenden
jahren das entsprechend aus finanzieren
und da werden wir darüber sprechen
müssen auch den gesamt etat das bmbf zu
erhöhen und ich wünsche der ministerin
ganz ganz viel erfolg bei den gesprächen
mit ihrem parteikollegen dazu und sie
haben uns sicher an ihrer seite
ich freue mich auf die umsetzung der im
haushalt angelegten projekte für gute
chancen für die menschen in diesem land
und für gute chancen für unser land ganz
herzlichen dank
nina starb anlass für bündnis 90 die
grünen im deutschen bundestag nächster
redner ist thomas jarzombek cdu csu
sprecher für bildung und forschung
war präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich möchte drei punkte heute
herausstellen die ich in dieser debatte
bemerkenswert finde das erste ist wir
haben darüber schon in der ersten
debatte geredet von ministerin nach 16
jahren union in denen dieser haushalt
für bildung und forschung sich fast
verdreifacht hat auf fast 22 milliarden
euro sind sie die erste die mit einer
delle nach hause gehen und wir sehen
diese delle nicht nur in diesem jahr
sondern auch noch im nächsten jahr und
es wird bis 25 dauern bis es ein anstieg
gibt und das bei einer inflationsrate
die wir im augenblick sehen sie
reduzieren die mittel für bildung und
forschung
und ich kenne das argument ich kenne das
argument jetzt entfallen ja die korona
mittel und ich kann ihnen nur sagen wenn
das ihr ernst machen sie einen großen
fehler das deutsche nationalem ins forum
hat erhoben dass bei den kindern in der
grundschule sind durch den
unterrichtsausfall kohona bis zu ein
gesamtes unterrichtsjahr entfallen wird
bis zum abschluss ein ganzes schuljahr
und wenn es einen zeitpunkt gibt wegen
corona in bildung zu investieren dann
ist das jetzt und wenn sie diese mittel
streichen ist das eine sünde an unseren
kindern
und frau ministerin sie haben im übrigen
ja auch noch probleme die über ihren
eigenen haushalt hinausgehen und die
probleme heißen tee und ein pci und bei
10 darüber haben wir auch schon
gesprochen das ist das zentrale programm
im mittelstand es hat fangen eine
hebelwirkung durch die privaten mittel
werden wir bis zu einem jahr ausfall
haben weil ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
im bmw k so hasenfüßig waren und haben
gesagt gegeben da kein geld aus bevor
dieser haushalt beschlossen sie haben
sich nicht dagegen die haben sich nicht
dagegen gewehrt das zweite ist das thema
gesundheit und bioökonomie wir haben
hier vorhin kollegin star hat gesagt wir
haben mittel impfmittel erfunden alle
diese unternehmen werden jetzt abwandern
denn gemeinsam mit anderen ländern haben
wir dieses zuerst gemacht eine halbe
milliarde ist das was deutschland
geplant hat 17 länder machen da jetzt
mit nur sie nicht weil zwischen lindner
und harbeck ein streit über die frage
entbrannt ist wer schuld ist oder nicht
das ende vom lied ist jetzt wird
gezeichnet und dinge wie christa kassen
ein sind hier entwickelt worden
verschaffen sie us-nobelpreisträger rinn
ist die chefin hierbei max planck in
berlin und die werden alle nach
frankreich gehen weil sie da
fördermittel bekommen sollen hier diese
halbe milliarde fehlt ich finde das ist
ein desaster
so dann haben sie dann haben sie dann
haben sie zwei dinge versprochen das
erste ist startchancen das startchancen
programm es ist nicht da was ist
stattdessen da die bereinigungssitzung
hat ihn ins buch geschrieben sie muss
jetzt endlich mal liefern bis zum 19 ich
bin gespannt darauf ich hab den eindruck
sie haben hier ein programm gebaut was
natürlich die bedürfnisse trifft aber
was sie gar nicht produzieren können
denn ohne eine grundgesetzänderung
können sie den ländern noch
blankoschecks geben und was daraus dann
resultieren kann das wissen wir durch
den digital park das wissen wir aber
auch durch das gewohnte programm so und
jetzt bleibt ich bin mal gespannt wie
sie das problem lösen wollen
startchancen an den start zu bringen
ohne den ländern einfach nur und land zu
geben und
und dann haben sie uns vorgeworfen wir
hätten mit dem pf ihren haushalt
versteinert ich glaube das spricht auch
eine sprache wie man es hätte
finanzieren wollen und ich bin ehrlich
gesagt froh dass wir den feri den pakt
für forschung innovation gemacht haben
um die wissenschaftseinrichtungen zu
schützen zu schützen vor kürzungen für
andere zwecke als wirklich die
wissenschaft nach vorne zu bringen
ihr zweites highlight vorhaben neben
startchancen das war die daten und es
ist sicher ein total bemerkenswerter
zufall dass ihr staatssekretär
sattelberger just an dem morgen um
entlassung gebeten hat als der
haushaltsausschuss in der nacht die
doppel sperre
die doppelt sie doppelt die doppel
sperre auf den daten gelegt hat sie
haben es ja vorhin gehört erst der
finanzminister dann auch noch einmal der
haushaltsausschuss so
und das ding es doch folgendes sie haben
jetzt wird nur 19 und mit mario
brandburg als neuem staatssekretär das
zu machen was christian lindner immer
gepredigt hat nämlich auch eine kultur
des scheiterns und zwar im positiven
einen neustart zu machen dati war völlig
verfahren mit 120 regional managern mit
konzeptionen die in alle richtungen
zeigen mit einem staatssekretär
sattelberger der sich mit allen in der
szene zerstritten hat sie nutzen sie die
chance für den neu starten positionieren
sie dass neu sie können zwei dinge tun
sie können zwei dinge tun sie können das
machen was in der debatte hier auch
schon mal vorkam wie bei es ein programm
machen mit dem sie konkrete
forschungsvorhaben unterstützen gerade
im hd bereich das würde auf jeden fall
helfen das funktioniert in der schweiz
einen sehr schlanken team von 70
vollzeitäquivalenten gucken sie sich das
mal an ob das so das thema forschen an
der haw nicht ein geeignetes mittel ist
und das zweite ist wir brauchen mehr in
der spitzenforschung und da brauchen sie
andere instrumente professor helmut
schönenberger der chef von unternehmer
tun hat sich doch an uns gewendet und
hat sein konzept mit dem er wirklich
erfolgreich ist an der tu münchen so
viele unicorns aus gegründet hat hat
angeboten ist auch anderen zur verfügung
zu stellen und an den top universitäten
auszurollen ich glaube wenn sie diese
beiden dinge machen nehmen sie das
angebot von helmut schönberger an und
nehmen sich das modell industries für
die hws dann haben sie eine echte chance
hier wirklich was für die innovation in
deutschland hin zu bringen und ein
allerletztes wort auch das thema
kernfusion bei vorhin meine frage nicht
beantwortet werden wollte da geht es
nicht nur um die magnet verfahren von
etat sondern da geht es um laser fusion
da hat der sattelberger mal geschrieben
dass es gute müssen investieren wir
haben das beantragte zum schluss sehr
zusammen weggehen
thomas jarzombek war das hat hier
deutlich andere gründe
vermutet thomas sattelberger hat selber
angegeben aus gesundheitlichen und
privaten gründen um seine entlassung
gebeten zu haben
nun kommt aber die bundesministerin
bettina stark watzinger
sehr geehrt auch präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt habe ich
mir schon einiges anhören können und ich
will auch das ein oder andere gleich
antworten aber zu beginn ist mir eines
wichtig ich möchte einfach einmal danke
sagen danke dass der haushaltsentwurf
steht danke liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass sie bildung und forschung
richtet
und es gibt eine redensart
es gibt eine redensart weniger ist
manchmal mehr ich musste hier heute
lernen dass wir einige im haus auch mehr
manchmal weniger ist nämlich zu den
fakten zurück 20,3 milliarden euro
investieren wir dieses jahr in bildung
und forschung das sind über zwei
milliarden euro mehr als 2009 10 den
letzten haushalt von corona mehr als in
ihrer mittelfristigen finanzplanung das
muss unser maßstab sein nicht die
ausnahme zeiten
an den niederrhein haben wir 2022 einen
klaren mittel aufwuchs und diese
richtung nach oben halten wir bis
2026 planen wir über vier milliarden
euro mehr als die vorgängerregierung
damit wir die investitionen in forschung
und entwicklung endlich auch 3,5 prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes bis 2025
steigern wir halten unsere zusagen wir
sorgen für investitionen in die zukunft
aber
erstmals
2022 mehr geld ist immer schön aber der
erfolg der bildungs und
forschungspolitik ist vor allem davon
abhängig die richtigen prioritäten zu
setzen und deswegen ist der vorliegende
haushalt ein guter haushalt und er ist
ein auch bessere als zuvor weil wir uns
einer der wichtigsten herausforderungen
stellen der forschung die uns hilft den
klimawandel noch besser zu verstehen und
die richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
damit wir nicht am status busch rauben
sondern mit neuen technologien wohlstand
mit schutz der umwelt versöhnen dieser
haushalt ist ein guter haushalt weil wir
den bau der polarstern zwei ausschreiben
können damit entsteht ein schiff
das überraschen und neue inventionen
ermöglicht und es ist ein guter haushalt
weil wir mehr geld für die forschung zur
energietechnologien und grünem
wasserstoff haben grüner wasserstoff als
chance für unser jahrhundert denn eins
ist klar nur mit innovation schützen wir
unseren blauen planeten
und als ambitioniertes und innovatives
land nehmen wir den auftrag an die
großen fragen zu beantworten dazu
brauchen wir noch mehr mut souveränität
und neue allianzen
neue souveränität bedeutet wir müssen in
deutschland und in der europäischen
union selbst in der lage sein
schlüsseltechnologien zu verstehen zu
entwickeln und zu produzieren und
deshalb investieren den forschungs
schlüsseltechnologien ki quanten cyber
security oder mikroelektronik
biotechnologie
technologische souveränität ermöglicht
uns die freie partnerwahl
aber sie ist nicht das ende aller
kooperation im gegenteil sie erfordert
neue allianzen mit gemeinsamen
interessen mit gemeinsam werden deswegen
auch die forschungs kooperation zum
grünen wasserstoff und zur biodiversität
mit australien deshalb auch die kontakte
zu den usa und kanada denn ja wir müssen
kurzfristig fossile energien aus
schwierigen ländern holen aber unser
ziel ist ganz klar wir wollen saubere
energien aus anderen demokratie nutzen
dass es unser auftrag
und gute partnerschaft das stichwort bei
transfers exzellente wissenschaft haben
wir aber es muss noch öfter und
schneller gelingen neues in die praxis
und an den markt zu bringen und die
deutsche agentur für transferieren
innovation kurz dati soll neue
partnerschaften beschleunigen regionale
innovations- ist ökosysteme auf und
ausbauen unser ziel im kleinen ansätzen
aber groß denken und her ja schon
wirklich fand ihre worte menschliche
eben wirklich daneben das muss ich jetzt
stellen statt diese schritte unserer
entwicklung innovation wird dafür mehr
spielraum erhalten am sprint freiheits
gesetz arbeiten wir gerade denn wir
wollen aufbrechen in einem jahrzehnte
innovation dafür legen wir mit diesem
haushalt den grundstein wenn wir auf die
bildung schauen dann zeigt sich auch
hier geld alleine macht nicht
deutschland liegt bei den ausgaben pro
schülerinnen und schüler über dem oecd
durchschnitt
doch bei dem was rauskommt den leistung
erreichen wir oft nur mittelmaß das
zeigt das geld muss richtig eingesetzt
werden bei den schulen und berufsschulen
universitäten und deswegen ist 2022 auch
ein gutes jahr die bafög-reform haben
wir unter hochdruck angestoßen 2,3
milliarden euro dafür in dieser
legislaturperiode 2,3 milliarden für
mehr chancengerechtigkeit mehr
reichweite mehr flexibilität in diesem
haushalt und ich freue mich ich freue
mich auf der staatsstraße programm mehr
als 4000 allgemeinen berufsbildende
schulen werden hier stärken
zukunftsvertrag studium lehre
planungssicherheit für den bund wie für
die hochschulen und lassen den ich das
letzte sagen weil wir es gerade gestern
vorgestellt haben ob digitalisierung
klima wandeln corona pandemie wenn man
mittendrin steckt sieht man es als krise
aber man kann auch von distributionen
sprechen und neu schaffen aber wo man
wenn man hinschaut sieht man einst
überall steckt mittendrin und deswegen
haben gestern den winter aktionsplans
vorgestellt mehr kooperation die
familien einbeziehen mehr qualität
forschung miteinander für unsere
wirtschaft und unsere zivilgesellschaft
und wir sehen uns in kürze wieder für
den hauptteil 2023 unsere prioritäten
bleiben solide haushaltspolitik und
trotzdem bei investitionen in unsere
zukunft bleiben wir für das chance
ministerium und tempo bei unserem
vorhaben jeder der mitglied ist herzlich
willkommen herzlich
für die fdp fraktion hat auch die
markierungen mit
spot-markt jungen sitzt im ausschuss für
bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
frau präsidentin frau ministerin meine
damen und herren
wissenschaft lebt vom ergebnisoffener
forschung und angstfreie mit jürgen
habermas gesprochen herrschaftsfreie
diskussion der renommierte mathematiker
professor stefan luckhaus ist aus der
nationalen akademie der wissenschaften
leopoldina
ausgetreten weil diese die verbreitung
seiner forschungsergebnisse zu corona
massiv behindert hat wie er berichtete
die modellrechnungen von professor
luckhaus hatten die weitgehende
nutzlosigkeit der lockdown politik
ergeben das war offenbar nicht genehm
weil extrem peinlich für die regierung
ich will gar nicht unterstellen dass
jemand aus dem bildungs oder
gesundheitsministerium bei der
leopoldina angerufen und für repression
gesorgt habe wissenschaftliche karrieren
werden heute durchaus subtiler beendet
sandra kosten da die vorsitzende des
netzwerks wissenschaftsfreiheit spricht
von einem wachsenden klima
intellektueller unfreiheit an deutschen
universitäten dass ab einem gewissen
punkt im intellektuellen lockdown ende
zitat ende und das meine damen und
herren ist ein unerträglicher zustand
und es müsste gerade sie von der fdp
frau bildungsministerin massiv
alarmierend da müssten sie doch
gegensteuern stattdessen lassen sie die
ford förderung der ideologischen so
genannten agenda wissenschaften einfach
weiterlaufen wie gender studies
postkoloniale studies und so weiter die
wissenschaft als wiedergutmachungs
projekt für angeblich benachteiligte
gruppen betreiben die jeden als
angreifer bekämpfen und als rechts
diffamieren der zu anderen ergebnissen
kommt und die auch vor der neuen und
naturwissenschaftlicher fakten wie der
zweigeschlechtlichkeit des menschen
nicht zurückschrecken und solange ein
solches klima herrscht und immer stärker
wird können wir ihrer im prinzip
sinnvollen förderung der
wissenschaftskommunikation nicht
zustimmen die gefahr ist einfach derzeit
so groß dass die wissenschaft hier für
gesellschaftspolitische ziele
missbraucht wird man könnte auch sagen
dass propaganda unter wissenschaftlichem
deckmantel betrieben wird und wenn sie
wenn sie die durchsetzung sogenannter
chancengerechtigkeit von frauen und
männern mit 33 millionen euro weiter
fördern wollen so ist das ein
etikettenschwindel da es nicht auf
chancengleichheit sondern auf starre
frauenquoten hinausläuft die zahllose
hoch qualifizierte männer in der
wissenschaft bereits in die resignation
getrieben haben das ist so lesen sie das
bitte mal nach wir informieren sie sich
mal woanders als nur bei ihren ideologen
auch das ist das gegenteil von liberal
frau stark watzinger wir haben die
streichung dieser mittel beantragt was
wir stattdessen wollen deutlich mehr
geld für fachhochschulen und angewandte
wissenschaften in deutschland sind
zurzeit 150 tausend stellen für
ingenieure vakant so viele wie nie zuvor
jedes jahr fehlen 26.000 absolventen in
den mint fächern wie uns das deutsche
institut für deutsche institut der
deutschen wirtschaft vor zwei tagen
wieder mitgeteilt hat es muss hier
dringend eine schwerpunktverlagerung
in der forschungsförderung stattfinden
weniger ideologie mehr mit mehr
pragmatismus das sind auch gute ansätze
vorhanden das wollen wir anerkennen
damit wir die wichtigste ressource die
wir haben in diesem land die bildung das
wissen und das können menschen optimal
wieder einsetzen vielen dank
mag jungen fordert forschungsfreiheit
spricht sich aber zugleich zum beispiel
gebend enders radies aus oliver
kaczmarek jetzt für die spd fraktion
meine damen und herren das ist der erste
von vier von mindestens vier haushalten
die wir uns vorgenommen haben in der
ampelkoalition um um seine reform
auftrag in unserem koalitionsvertrag
umzusetzen und ich finde er zeigt in
eine klare richtung auch wenn noch nicht
der ganze vertrag umgesetzt worden ist
und zwar eine klare richtung für neue
akzente in der forschungspolitik für die
unterstützung der hochschulen und für
die entlastung von studierenden
auszubildenden und herr jarzombek ich
habe ihre rede gehört ich fand sie mutig
eingedenk ihrer eigenen leistung
schreiben sie doch mal antrag das haben
sie bis jetzt noch nicht geschafft in
dieser wahlperiode dann können uns auch
mal mit ihren vorstellungen aus setzen
sie tänzeln durch die themen durch wir
handeln und das wird in diesem
haushaltsentwurf deutlich ich möchte
drei beispiele nennen
wir stärken forschung für die
herausforderungen der zukunft und wir
setzen mit der förderung von transfer
nach der jahrelangen diskussion auch in
der großen koalition endlich in einen
neuen besonderen akzent und ich will nur
das sagen wir sind ja in der
konzepterarbeitung wenn man das mal
richtig machen will dann bezieht man
stakeholder 1 aber das wichtige signal
nach quälenden jahren der diskussion mit
der union die deutsche agentur für
transfers innovation wird kommen und das
ist gut und das ein meilenstein in
unserer forschungspolitik und
darüber hinaus stärken wir auch die
grundlagenforschung gold grundlagen und
anwendungsorientierte forschung zusammen
gehören meeresforschung wird gestört die
gefolge verhört wie gestärkt die
gesundheitsforschung wird gestärkt die
polarstern wird endlich gebaut auch so
ein thema über das wir jahrelang
diskutiert haben und die
gesellschaftswissenschaften forschung
wählt priorität für die lösung der
zukunftsfragen sie bekommt von uns dafür
einen verlässlichen rahmen
ein weiterer wichtiger punkt die
hochschulen sind das herz unseres
wissenschaftssystems und die reden nicht
nur darüber wie stärken sie besonderer
weise die innovation in der lehre sind
schon angesprochen worden ich möchte
einmal nur kurz sagen ich bin dem
haushaltsausschuss sehr dankbar für den
maßgaben beschluss zum zukunftsvertrag
für studium und lehre denn das ist ein
ganz wichtiges signal dass wir deutlich
machen das wichtigste
finanzierungsinstrument für
studienplätze dass bund und länder haben
wir zukünftig aufwachsen jährlich
planbar und dynamisiert dass es ein
gutes zeichen und wir freuen uns dass
wir jetzt schon hören dass wir
beispielsweise die
hochschulrektorenkonferenz bei diesem
projekt an unserer seite haben auch ein
meilenstein für unsere
wissenschaftspolitik
und ich möchte das noch einmal
wiederholen was kollegin esther schon
gesagt hat wir verbinden damit natürlich
auch die erwartung auch mit der novelle
des wissenschafts zeit vertrags gesetz
ist dass wir jetzt die verlässlichen
rahmenbedingungen dafür nutzen dass wir
eben stabile und damit auch unbefristete
beschäftigung karriereoptionen bekommen
denn wir gehen davon aus dass sich nur
so die besten köpfe weiterhin gewinnen
lassen eine karriere im
wissenschaftssystem anzustreben und wir
werden das wissenschafts zeit vertrags
gesetz entsprechend ausstatten mit einem
entsprechenden rahmen versehen für
stabile beschäftigung in der
wissenschaft
[Applaus]
und zum schluss weil das wichtig ist in
zeiten steigender preise haben wir als
koalition die menschen mit kleinen
einkommen in besonderer weise im blick
und das gilt insbesondere auch für
auszubildende und für studierende für
uns ist wichtig dass wir deutlich machen
wir haben respekt vor ihrer leistung und
weil sie respekt vor ihrer leistung
haben unterstützen wir euch auch in
diesen schwierigen zeiten und ich will
fünf punkte nennen die jetzt ganz direkt
studierenden und auszubildenden zu gute
kommen werden erstens werden das bafög
massiv ausbreiten ab dem ersten august
werden wesentlich mehr menschen einen
anspruch auf bafög haben und den antrag
stellen können und dann auch bafög
bekommen können 2 alle die jetzt schon
dafür bekommen oder die
berufsausbildungsbeihilfe bekommen ab
dem sommer bekommen im sommer ohne
antrag zusätzlich ausgezahlt einen
heizkostenzuschuss von 230 euro das ist
garantiert das haben wir schon
beschlossen und das hilft
uns das neun euro ticket das in diesen
tagen so erfolgreich anläuft wird auch
studierende entlasten denn das wird den
preis für das semesterticket zum wir
sind zum wintersemester deutlich
reduzieren auch eine entlastung vierter
und frau volquartz gerade wiederholt ist
es bleibt falsch dass sie gesagt haben
natürlich bekommen auch studieren und
zwar solche die einen mini job haben die
energiepreis pauschale in höhe von 300
euro wir wissen das sind drei viertel
aller studierenden das bild ganz konkret
ich würde sie einfach hinten dabei den
fakten zu bleiben und fünftens
studierende und auszubildende mit kind
erhalten pro kind ab juli mit dem
kindergeld ausgezahlt einen einmal bonus
von 100 euro meine damen und herren wir
haben wirklich viel bewegt und
studierende und auszubildende von
steigenden preisen zu entlasten das ist
richtig das ist überfällig und wenn es
notwendig ist werden wir da auch noch
nachlegen herzlichen dank
oliver kaczmarek hat hier noch einmal
verschiedene aspekte bezüglich der
förderung von schülerinnen schülern und
studierenden aufgegriffen unter anderem
gab er die kritik dass die zusätzlichen
gelder mit der information verpuffen
meine damen und herren co wird es nicht
vorbei die viren werden sich von unseren
beschlüssen nicht begrenzen lassen nur
vom handeln und die wissenschaft warnt
uns es wird nicht die letzte solche sein
die aus einem corona beer es entsteht
auch in zukunft werden wir verstärkt mit
zu rosen also krankheiten die zwischen
tieren und menschen übertragen werden
rechnen müssen dass die beziehung
zwischen mensch tier umwelt haben sich
zwar komplex aber zunehmend konflikt
haft entwickelt dass sie nun die mittel
für gesundheitsforschung
medizintechnik und globales gesundheit
reduzieren weil die pandemie nicht mehr
vordergründig in schlagzeilen auftaucht
bleibt hoch riskant
sie haben gekürzt um ein viertel haben
sie den titel gekürzt erzählen sie mir
nicht dass sie um verteilt haben das
nicht vollständig um verteilt wurden das
ist jetzt 13 millionen sind für die
kogit forschung ist zwar sehr günstig
aber eigentlich brauchen wir das
zehnfache deshalb müssen wir an der
stelle weiter reden
kurzum die forschung zu
krankheitserregern und zur pandemie
bekämpfung bleibt wichtig sie zu
vernachlässigen kostet wieder
menschenleben sie wird wieder viel teure
für die gesellschaft und vor allem
kostet sie auch vertrauen in
wissenschaft und
politik zudem longo wird oder eben auch
post kogit wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen wir sprechen hier von zehn
prozent der infizierten
mehr noch das erschöpfungssyndrom nach
viralen erkrankungen sie haben ja selber
so ein beispiel von erzählt frau ist da
durchkreuzt auf dramatische weise
lebenspläne und
350.000 menschen sind allein in
deutschland betroffen und davon vor
allem junge leute auf meine kritische
nachfrage ob es die ob des geringen
mittelansatz oder zu geringen mittel
ansatzes im ministerium meinte man das
krankheitsbild sei noch nicht klar
bestimmt na logisch da muss man eben
forschen das ist doch der sinn der
ganzen
die krank ich weiß sie haben sich sehr
bemüht das will ich auch in rechnung
stellen die erkrankten haben keine zeit
wir brauchen schnell das geld und die
studien müssen schnell finanziert werden
voran sich also die pandemie täuschung
bitte nicht zurück jetzt an post kogit
grundlagen an diagnosen therapien und
versorgung zur kuscheligen schützt uns
menschen und das liegt in unserer
verantwortung danke
soweit die sprecherin für forschungs-
technologie- und innovationspolitik der
linksfraktion petra sitte anna
christmann ist nun die nächste rednerin
für die grünen-fraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir diskutieren heute über den 31
forschung und bildung und ich möchte das
noch mal in den kontext setzen in der
situation in der wir insgesamt gerade
sind wir haben als regierung und auch
ein teil natürlich gemeinsam auch als
parlament gerade eine ungeheure krise
einen krieg in europa zu begleiten zu
unterstützen das dort mutigen hilfen
hingehen und in dieser zeit gelingt es
uns als ampel aber diese wichtigen
themen wie innovation wie forschung wie
die fragen welche technologien brauchen
wir denn für die herausforderungen die
noch kommen diesen etat noch mal
aufwachsen zu lassen im vergleich zum
ersten regierungsentwurf das ist nämlich
die tatsache und ich glaube das ist ein
sehr wichtiger erfolg dieser regierung
gerade in diesen zeiten die
investitionen in forschung und
innovation zu erhöhen
und wir haben ja leider auch an einigen
stellen aufzuräumen das betrifft dann
eben nicht nur diesen einzigen klaren
zimt ist erwähnt worden dass es ja dort
auch die nachlässigkeit der
vorgängerregierung die wir dort zu
beheben haben es war eben nicht in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung
ausfinanziert daher fahren bis zu dem
antragsstopp das haben wir geändert auch
dort gibt es jetzt die nächsten jahren
aufwuchs von 80 millionen auf das ein
richtiges zeichen für forschung im
bereich des mittelstands
wir wollen aber natürlich auch neue
projekte anstoßen tun das auch sehr
kräftig und da möchte ich auch nochmal
thomas sattelberger für seine leistung
den ersten monaten danken dass er das
projekt daten wirklich sehr engagiert
auf den weg gebracht hat und wir wollen
zügig sein und entscheidend ist immer
beim thema da die aus meiner sicht auch
dass es wirklich um eine neue form auch
der innovationsförderung bei uns im land
gehen wird das macht es auch wirklich
zum meilenstein wir wollen damit
wirklich verschiedene akteure
zusammenbringen sind seines die haw
seien es aber auch start up sein ist die
kommunen seien es natürlich der
mittelstand diese akteure in einer ganz
neuen form in innovationsprojekten
zusammenzubringen das ist das was das
innovationspotenzial unseres landes
heben wird und das ist auch ein schritt
zu einem neuen förderinstrument als
aufforderung anders denkt als klassisch
in drei jahren forschungsprojekten wie
wir sie kennen und das macht es zu einem
so wichtigen projekt in deswegen freue
ich mich dass wir damit in diesem jahr
schon mit mitteln auch anfangen kann und
bin überzeugt dass wir gerade auch mit
der stakeholder beteiligung und jetzt
mit der ausgestaltung der letzten
eckpunkte dann sehr erfolgreiches
projekt starten wird
ums aufräumen geht es ja in der satz
auch so ein bisschen bei sprint das war
gut dass diese agentur gegründet worden
ist aber sie hat eben enge fesseln
angelegt bekommen das ändern wir jetzt
mit dem sprint freiheits gesetz und auch
schon in diesem haushalt mit einem
ordentlichen aufwuchs für projekte der
stimmt denn die sprung innovationen die
brauchen wir ja gerade gerade auch um
die klima themen zu lösen ganz
erfolgreiche erste wettbewerber gerade
zum thema wie man zb co2 in wertvollen
produkten binden kann das sind die dinge
die wir in zukunft noch stärker brauchen
für die man aber auch eine freiheit in
der förderpolitik braucht deswegen freue
ich mich sehr über den aufwuchs auf 790
millionen für die sprint in diesem jahr
und das freiheits gesetz dass wir jetzt
auch zügig umsetzen werden
wir wollen aber natürlich auch in den
nächsten jahren noch viele dinge die im
koalitionsvertrag ganz richtig
festgehalten sind jetzt natürlich
antreiben ich will hier die
zukunftsstrategie explizit benennen die
auch noch mal dafür steht dass wir von
einer hightech strategie die ja doch
etwas in die jahre gekommen ist zu einer
zukunftsstrategie kommen wollen sie
wirklich ganz klar einzelne missionen
benennt und weil sie so wichtig sind
möchte ich sie einmal noch mal nennen
wir wollen sechs missionen
anstoßen zur privaträumen industrie zu
einem klima rahmenprogramm zur
gesundheit zur digitalisierung
insbesondere bei ihren kranken fünftens
auch zum weltraum und meeresforschung
und sechs zum thema resilienz und
zusammenhalt denn auch gerade die
sozialwissenschaftlichen disziplinen
sind natürlich ganz entscheiden für
zukunftsfragen sechs missionen die es
ganz engagiert anzugehen gilt und ich
freue mich aber die gewährte auch wie
wir diese dann umsetzen werden auch da
freue ich mich forschungsförderung
vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen neu zu
denken über die frage wie wir auch
projektsteuerung dieser einzelnen
missionen aufsetzen weil wir auch dort
noch meine neue kraft in einem
übergreifenden ansatz entwickeln können
und in diesem sinne freue ich mich dass
er auch die zukunftsstrategie die kommen
wird
die alte koalition steht damit für einen
echten aufbruch im bereich forschung und
innovation den brauchen wir auch
angesichts der herausforderungen und ich
freue mich darauf dass es dieses jahr
damit schon losgeht und wir in den
nächsten jahren weiter sicher sehr gut
vorankommen werden
[Applaus]
für die unionsfraktion hat dann hier
durch das bot
erst glas dann kurz darauf
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen frau ministerin sie haben in
letzter zeit des öfteren
das wort des chancen ministeriums für
ihr haus verwendet seien sie mir nicht
böse wenn ich sage unser eindruck ist er
es ist das haus der verpassten chancen
und nicht der vollumfänglich genutzten
chancen meine kollegen haben dazu
natürlich auch schon einiges einiges
gesorgt wir haben den fokus bisher stark
gelegt auf forschung und hochschule ich
möchte in ein bisschen verschieben und
wir im blick wenden auf die
frühkindliche bildung denn auch die
frühkindliche bildung ist eine wichtige
grundlage mit ihr haben wir uns ganz
ganz verstärkt auseinanderzusetzen ja
natürlich weiß ich dass es überwiegend
ländersache wir wissen aber auch dass
wir gerade im moment zwei ganz große
herausforderungen vor der brust haben
und das eine ist natürlich der ukraine
krieg und die folgen der zuwandernden
schülerinnen und schülern unser
bildungssystem und das andere ist etwas
was sie alle in ihren reden ein bisschen
ausgeblendet haben ja es mag schon sein
dass wir im moment gute instanzen haben
aber die folgen der puro pandemie ist
besondere bei schülerinnen und schülern
aber auch bei kita kindern sind nach wie
vor da und wann wenn nicht jetzt wollen
wir diese folgen dann auch angehen und
bekämpfen wann wenn nicht jetzt wollen
wir damit beginnen und zwar mit vollgas
die lücken die sich naturgemäß durch
homeschooling et cetera aufgetan haben
zu füllen jetzt muss es passieren und
dazu habe ich heute von ihnen bisher
fast gar nichts gehört und das tut mir
leid für die kinder in diesem land
und ja es ist richtig das programm auch
von noch bewohner dass wir auf gesetzt
haben natürlich muss es fortgesetzt
werden aber es muss natürlich
dynamisiert werden warum ist das so wir
haben schon gehört eine repräsentative
studie unter unter grundschülern hat
massive lesen schwächen offenbart
massive leseschwächen wissenschaftler
des deutschen jugendinstituts und srk
berichten in ihrem jüngsten
quartalsbericht der korona kita studie
über wirklich verheerende und
erschreckende entwicklungen insbesondere
natürlich in familien die auch sonst ist
schwer haben für ihre kinder die
entsprechende förderung vielleicht
selber bereitzustellen die ihnen
vielleicht die sensibilität dafür fehlt
und deswegen ist es für uns und lassen
sie mich den sprung in den einzelplan 17
einfach kurz machen absolut
unverständlich dass man unseren antrag
auf erhöhung des titels sprach kitas
abgelehnt hat denn die sprache ist die
grundlage dafür dass es gut läuft in der
kita und dann später auch in der schule
und dass wir hier heute so wenig von
ihnen gehört haben ist eine ganz ganz
große enttäuschung
das zweite ist das thema ganztagsschule
und rechtsanspruch darauf in wir in der
großen koalition noch beschlossen haben
da kommt eine riesige herausforderung
nicht nur auf die länder zu sondern auch
auf die kommunen und auch hier haben wir
gefordert schon heute
finanziell für die beschleunigung des
kinderbetreuungs ausbaus etwas zu tun
ist bedauerlicherweise von ihnen auch
abgelehnt worden genauso bitter ist es
übrigens genauso bitte ist es übrigens
in zeiten von dem größten
fachkräftemangel denen wir uns
wahrscheinlich vorstellen können dass
sie es ablehnen die mittel bei der
qualifizierung auch bei der beruflichen
bildung zu erhöhen ganz ganz bittere
botschaft für dieses land und für die
frage wir bekämpfen wir den
fachkräftemangel und das vierte thema es
wird auch schon angesprochen worden
startchancen programm gehören nicht an
gestern nicht angekündigt die
ankündigungen jetzt so weit dass die
regierungskoalitionen sich gezwungen
sollen damit überhaupt noch was an den
puschen kommen maßnahme beschluss auf
den weg zu bringen sonst hätten wir
vermutlich noch länger darauf gewartet
dass heros vorwärtsgeht wir sind sehr
gespannt frau ministerin ob sie es
schaffen bis zum herbst hier konkrete
dinge vorzulegen denn das wird noch eine
ganz ganz große herausforderung für uns
alle
und deswegen bin ich ehrlicherweise
schon der meinung so der ganz große wurf
bei uns hier verkauft werden soll ist es
immer noch nicht wir sind aber gerne
bereit und das haben wir glaube ich auch
mit unserem verhalten in der
bereinigungssitzung bewiesen obwohl sie
alle unsere änderungsanträge runter
gestimmt haben waren wir schon immer
lage über unseren schatten zu springen
und die die von ihrer seite gut waren
mitzutragen weil wir konstruktiv
unterwegs sind und gerne mithelfen
wollen dass bildung in forschung in
diesem land eine zukunft hat dann halt
mit uns und der opposition und deswegen
kann ich weiterhin nur anbieten wir sind
gerne bereit mit zu tun aber es müssen
mehr voraus zu brauchen als die diese
uns heute geliefert haben film
sagt daniela ludwig für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und nächster redner ist
stefan seiler von den liberalen im
deutschen bundestag mitglied im
ausschuss für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
kollegen es sollte uns ja allen klar
sein dass forschung und entwicklung
wichtige voraussetzung sind und
krisensituationen zu bekämpfen sich der
aus der wissenschaft kommt letzten 30
jahre in der wissenschaft gearbeitet
habe hatte in der vergangenheit in den
letzten 16 jahren nicht immer den
eindruck dass das in
der regierung wirklich auch geteilt wird
und das war für mich ein punkt auch in
die politik zu gehen und ich muss sagen
die ampel koalition legt jetzt einen
haushalt vor der erste elemente an um
neuen fortschritts orientierten
wissenschaftspolitik fahren kann und wir
werden damit den herausforderungen
seiner zeit gerecht denn es werden alle
drei ebenen der forschung war sie
adressiert grundlagenforschung
angewandter forschung und transfer
nein es kommt nicht so cool aus
es geht aktuell für die herausforderung
die angewandte forschung und transfer
stärker zu fördern mit der gestiegenen
förderung der hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaft mit der partie werden wir
auf diesem weg erfolgreich gehen und da
haben sie mir an dieser stelle eine
anmerkung übertrag kollege jahr zum bett
das zusammenfallen von zwei ereignissen
zu einem zeitpunkt heißt noch nicht dass
eine ursache wirkung vorliegt und das
sollte man gerade bei solchen themen
berücksichtigen meiner meinung
forschungspolitik muss vielmehr auch
noch mehr als bislang die
technologisches souveränität unseres
landes berücksichtigen weil die
technologische souveränität schafft es
sichert uns dass wir im systemwettbewerb
weiterhin einfluss nehmen können es war
die wirtschaftliche stärke unseres
landes genauso wie die technologie
intensität unserer volkswirtschaft die
die position deutschlands in der
vergangenheit gesichert in solchen
verhandlungen und ich bin sicher dass
wir mit dem neuen team im ministerium
genau der wissenschafts community ein
signal geben und ihn vor allem die
sicherheit geben eine forschungspolitik
zu machen die zu neuen sich wendet
nämlich das wissenschaftssystem zu
befähigen
technologieoffen innovationen zu
schaffen die notwendig sind um unsere
herausforderungen zu bewältigen
aber meine damen und herren es geht
nicht nur um finanzielle ausstattung von
dem sie dann schon durch eine
zwischenfrage aus der abdullah
es geht nicht nur um die finanzielle
ausstattung von forschungsaktivitäten
sondern es geht auch um das thema
bürokratie
antragsverfahrens hin zu komplex dauern
zu lange und halten unsere forscherinnen
und forscher nämlich von dem ab was sie
nämlich gerne tun und vor allem gut
machen nämlich einerseits forschen
fragen stellen und die dann auch lösen
und beantworten und die andere wird mit
der entbürokratisierung
dieses bewältigen und ich bin sicher
dass wir damit erfolgreich die
herausforderung unserer zeit bewältigen
können vielen dank
[Applaus]
soweit steffen stefan reiter für die
fdp-fraktion der bundestag diskutiert
über den einzelplan 30 bildung und
forschung und wir verlassen aber die
heutige debatte wir sind natürlich
morgen dann wieder da ab 8 uhr 45 dann
werden zum abschluss der
bundestagsdebatte wir katja mast und
thorsten frei im interview haben es geht
hier dann ja um den punkte arbeit und
soziales aber auch um das
haushaltsgesetz
2022 die schlussberatung und aber auch
das sondervermögen bundeswehr wird dann
hier eine rolle spielen wird diskutiert
werden und abgestimmt werden die 100
milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr hier
geht es jetzt weiter mit der
dokumentation ohne öl und gas die
energie von morgen bleiben sie fall
phoenix
wirtschaft uns mittel bei den
außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen sowie die
ausfinanzierung der modernisierung der
deutschen forschungsschiffs flotte
stichwort polarstern 2 bezüglich der
errichtung des internationalen
teilchenbeschleuniger projektes in
darmstadt auch für projekt genannt
wollen dir dass das angestrebte
zwischenziel trotz mehr kostenrisiken
erreicht werden muss dieses
vorzeigeprojekt physikalische
grundlagenforschung ist zwar
kostenintensiv aber die investition
haben großes potenzial langfristig viele
neue erkenntnisse und innovationen
hervorzubringen
kritisch sehen hier das mit der die eine
weitere agentur eingerichtet werden soll
um anwendungsorientierte forschung an
fachhochschulen zu unterstützen frau
ministerin wir haben bereits eine bund
länder vereinbarung zur unterstützung
der forschung an fachhochschulen
diese gilt es nach ihrem auslaufen
nächstes jahr weiter zu stärken und
auszubauen das wäre der richtige weg wir
brauchen keinen aufbau einer
doppelstruktur auf kosten des deutschen
steuerzahlers
die umsetzung des digital parks schule
läuft mehr als schleppend bei einem
basistakt in höhe von fünf milliarden
euro sind zum jahresende 2021 gerade
einmal 19 prozent der fördermittel
abgeflossen neben digitaler technik gibt
es eine noch viel größere baustelle
nämlich die marode substanz viele
schulgebäude
die aktuellen zahlen sind dramatisch und
ein armutszeugnis für die
bildungsrepublik deutschland
der immens hoher investitionsrückstand
von über 46 milliarden euro an schulen
belegt die anhaltende vernachlässigung
von schulgebäuden durch die bundesländer
um diesen negativtrend zu kippen haben
wir im bundeshaushalt 2022 einen antrag
eingebracht mit der forderung den
digital packt füllen einen zukunftspakt
uhle umzuwandeln und mit erweiterten
förderinstrumenten endlich auch
instandsetzungs investitionen an
schulgebäuden zu
ermöglichen ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
für die spd fraktion spreche zusätzlich
karossen dank
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen wir leben in extremen
herausfordernden zeiten und ja diese
feststellung gehört gerade hierher und
gerade in die beratung auch dieses
haushaltes zu recht liegt unser medialer
focus gerade ganz besonders auf der
bestmöglichen unterstützung der ukraine
bei ihrer selbstverteidigung trotzdem
dürfen wir aber nicht außer acht lassen
dass große teile unserer gesellschaft
bereits vor dem krieg stark belastet
waren die pandemie hat auch und gerade
die bildungsinstitutionen und all die
engagierten menschen die in ihnen lernen
und lehren getroffen und die folgen all
dessen sind nicht weg nur weil wir
weniger darüber reden gerade deshalb
haben es kinder und junge menschen
verdient das finde ich erst dass wenn
nicht erneut über den sommer vergessen
wie wichtig eine gute vorbereitung auf
den herbst und winter ist damit lernen
und gesund bleiben möglich ist die
vorbereitungen müssen jetzt das
hochlaufen
und genau das eingefordert haben schon
in diesem februar nicht gesundheits
expertinnen und politikerinnen sondern
schülerinnen und schüler selbst unter
dem hashtag wir werden laut haben sie
nicht nur eine vorsorgende corona
politik verlangt sondern zu recht
eingefordert hört auf politik über
unsere köpfe hinweg zu machen und gerade
weil es dieser koalition darum geht
endlich
politik mit und gerade mit jungen
menschen zu machen haben wir in diesem
haushalt endlich dafür gesorgt dass die
bundes schülerinnen konferenz mit einer
halben million euro ausgestattet wird
und schülerinnen und bundesweit
strukturen vorfinden können indem sie
sich organisieren können und eine laute
politische stimme sind die wir gerade
auch als spd aber auch als gesamte
ampelkoalition nicht überhören werden
und genau darum geht es übrigens auch in
der politik stil dieser ampel wir wollen
nicht zementieren und erstarren sondern
aus dem lernen was ist wir wollen nach
vorne gehen und modernisieren und
deshalb reicht es eben auch nicht die
unterschiedlichen bildungschancen zu
beklagen die durch corona ja noch
unterschiedlicher geworden sind sondern
wir müssen etwas tun und genau das
wollen wir tun das wollen wir machen mit
dem startchancen programm und liebe cdu
liebe csu das wird ja gerade in diesem
haushalt auch deutlich für uns geht es
also darum nicht zu erstarren wie es
viel zu oft in den letzten jahren der
fall war sondern für fortschritt
einzustehen und das tun wir ganz
besonders auch wenn es um die berufliche
bildung geht indem wir nämlich die
digitalisierung und modernisierung von
überbetrieblichen
berufsbildungsstätten vorantreiben
setzen wir den fokus auf die berufliche
bildung ist technisch aber es ist ein so
wichtiger lernort wo eben auch gerade
kleine unternehmen die möglichkeit haben
beste qualität herzustellen
und ich sage ganz deutlich dass es nur
der allererste schritt wir wollen das
noch viel weiter machen wir werden auch
gerade diese diesen ort zu einem
wichtigen pfeiler machen denn es umgeht
ausbildungsplatzgarantie geht in der so
viel in diesem feld noch vor uns liegt
und wo es auch im fortschritt geht um
modernisierung das ist die ganze frage
der weiterbildung es ist der zentrale
pfeiler wenn wir diese innovatives
innovationsland sein wollen und deshalb
geht es hierbei gerade darum in der
digitalisierung die chance zu sehen und
gerade auf unterschiedliche strukturen
die es in deutschland zweifelsohne gibt
die auch große hürden darstellen endlich
kleiner zu machen auch und gerade durch
die digitalisierung nicht klar auch für
meine fraktion es für uns richtig ist
dass alle unterschiedlichen gruppen
erreicht werden gerade die die
vielleicht negative bildungs erfahrungen
gemacht haben darum geht es und da ist
digitalisierung ein schlüssel vor allem
aber ein schlüssel dafür dass wir ein
flickenteppich der gerade besteht
endlich so strukturieren können dass die
informationen auch da ankommen wo sie
gebraucht werden und weiterbildung
endlich eine chance für alle ist
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger auch gerade
die die grade die hier zu hören heute
geht es um viele zahlen um
einzelprojekte aber am ende meine
fortschritts koalition modernisierung
dieses landes und wir gerade wir hier
wissen ohne die köpfe funktioniert das
alles nicht und deshalb investieren wir
in die vielen lieben dank
[Applaus]
neuer kraft hat das wort für bündnis 90
die
[Applaus]
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe gäste auf
der zuschauertribüne in deutschland
entscheidet immer noch viel zu häufig
das einkommen der eltern darüber wer
abitur macht oder eben nicht und das
gleiche gilt leider auch für das studium
durchschnittlich studieren drei von vier
akademikerkindern und gleichzeitig nur
eines von vier arbeiter kindern mit
echter bildungsgerechtigkeit davon sind
wir noch weit entfernt
und wir als ampel haben viel vor für die
nächsten jahre und wir werden jetzt im
bereich bildung und forschung die
weichen für die zukunft stellen
[Applaus]
wir wollen jungen menschen
bildungschancen ermöglichen unabhängig
von ihrer sozialen herkunft darum geht
es nämlich und deshalb haben wir als
ampel die bafög bitte um 130 millionen
euro aufgestockt damit erhöhen wir nicht
nur die bedarfssätze sondern wir
ermöglichen auch erheblich mehr
studierenden den zugang zu bafög und
somit auch zum studium
und welche koalition hat den bisher die
studierenden so entlastet wie unsere
frau burke also mir ist da keine
koalition bekannt
aber nicht nur das miranda wird auch für
ukrainische geflüchtete geöffnet damit
sie hier in deutschland ihr studium
fortsetzen können jemand der schon seine
heimat verloren hat der soll nicht auch
noch seine berufliche zukunft verlieren
müssen und dafür stellen wir zusätzliche
81,2 millionen euro allein im etat des
bmbf zur verfügung wir stehen zur
ukraine und wir wollen helfen wir wollen
helfen indem wir die beruflichen chancen
von geflüchteten studierenden auch vor
dem hintergrund eines wiederaufbaus der
ukraine verbessern wir wollen aber auch
im bereich der forschung auf die
brennenden themen der zeit blicken und
das bedeutet einfach mehr geld für die
technologien der zukunft die förderung
von bereichen die in den kommenden
jahren und jahrzehnten an bedeutung noch
weiter zunehmen werden das sind klima
und nachhaltigkeitsforschung zu
bekämpfen der klimakrise der haushalt
des bmbf ist und dieser richtung ein
bedeutender schritt
die klimaforschung gibt uns die
dringenden benötigten daten zur umwelt
und klima entwicklung je mehr wir dazu
in erfahrung bringen desto besser können
wir uns auch drohende katastrophen wie
dürren überschwemmungen aber auch das
artensterben das besser kann er darauf
reagieren und darüber hinaus freut es
mich ungemein dass das parlament die
finanzierung für den mörder des
großartigen forschungsschiff polarstern
2 auf die beine stellen konnte das haben
sie nicht auf die kette kriegt wo die
polarstern 2
ist nicht mit stiften wird wie ihre
vorgängerin
maßgebliche und weltweit einzigartige
polar und meeresforschung betreiben
deutschland kann bedeutsame
spitzenforschung vorantreiben und
gleichzeitig die voraussetzung für
evidenzbasierte klima und energiepolitik
schaffen klima und
nachhaltigkeitsforschung
das ist die zukunftsforschung
eine kürzung in diesem bereich wäre ein
fatales signal dass ein
zukunftsorientiertes ministerium
unbedingt verhindern muss das
ministerium ist deshalb auch am zug die
nötigen mittel im entwurf für den
haushalt 20 23 bereitzustellen
nach zwei jahren kann dem i ist die
aufstockung im bereich der
gesundheitsforschung nun mehr als
geboten die forschung zu impfstoffen zur
therapeutika zur post kowitz symptomen
von corona deal ist noch im vollen gange
aber gleichzeitig stehen schon die
nächsten 2000 vor der tür und in den
nächsten jahren muss hier deutlich
investiert werden
wir haben
wir haben dieses jahr schon ein auch die
beine gestellt und ich hoffe dass der
gesamte tafel des bmwf in zukunft noch
weiter aufgestockt wird und viele
projekte die wir vorhaben die einst
vereinen sie sind auf auskömmliche
finanzierung angewiesen und darum werden
wir auch in den nächsten
haushaltsverfahren hartnäckig bleiben
vielen dank
die kollegin nadine schön hat jetzt das
wort für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen seiner damen
und herren
zwei dinge nämlich aus dieser debatte
mit erstens die eigene leistung wird
nicht besser dadurch dass man die
leistungen anderer
nicht nur schlecht städte sondern mit
unwahrheiten hier präsentiert
ich will
nur noch einmal feststellen dass der
belag
der haushalt dieses bundesministeriums
ist in den letzten 16 jahren
kontinuierlich gestiegen seit
amtsantritt von angela merkel haben wir
den haushalt um das zweieinhalbfache
angehoben das ist die messlatte die auf
dem tisch liegt 250 prozent ich bin
gespannt ob sie das in den nächsten jahr
anbieten kommen
ja 16 jahre und dann sind wir wieder
ganz sind wir wieder beim punkt die
kollegen gold mit der ich selber einer
meinung bin hat es gesagt der haushalt
jetzt studie stagniert und natürlich
kann man die das aufholen paket nach
koronar ausrichten aber es ist auch
völlig richtig wir haben so viele
defizite bei den schülerinnen und
schülern dass es völlig unmöglich ist
sonderprogramme raus zu retten müsste
genau in diesem bereich besonders
investieren und deshalb bleibt wir haben
konnten wir dich den haushalt angehoben
jetzt starten jetzt und deshalb ist es
völlig falsch was sie hier versuchen den
eindruck zu erwecken
und das zweite ist das thema artig auch
hier man alle bafög waren die bafög
erhöhungen
prozentual höher als das was sie jetzt
machen sie haben eine bafög-erhöhung die
nicht einmal die inflation ausgleicht
und wenn es um den energie zuschuss geht
dann sagen sie eben allen studentinnen
und studenten die kein minijob oder kein
kind haben na ja ihr habt halt pech
gehabt auch hier gilt sich mal die
fakten anschauen und nicht die eigene
leistung dadurch besser machen dass man
mit dem finger auf andere zeigt
und liebe kollegen sie haben gesagt sie
wollen den haushalt in den kontext
herr frau
vor den herausforderungen wollen sie
eine zwischenfrage von der algerien zu
lassen
nur ganz kurz ich wollte noch mal
nachfragen frau schön ob das korrekt ist
dass die ehemalige
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck
beim letzten haushalt 800 millionen euro
bafög mittel an den bundesfinanzminister
hat zurückfließen lassen und sie das
bafög
stehen haben lassen und der
nachfolgeregierung übergeben haben nur
noch elf prozent geförderten quote ob
dass es die korrekten zahlen sind und
damit ja dann zur kenntnis nehmen können
dass wir jetzt gerade die größte
bafög-reform aller zeiten auf den weg
gebracht haben in wenigen monaten
völlig eingestellt dass man beim bafög
einen reformbedarf hat und zwar sowohl
was die höhe angeht als auch was die
struktur angeht sie haben jetzt in der
höhe nachgebessert die strukturellen
reformen kommen noch da haben sie uns
ganz auf ihrer seite ich würde ihnen
aber gerne die gegen fragen stellen ob
es stimmt dass sie den bafög titel
eingerechnet haben in die globale
minderausgabe so dass man davon ausgehen
dass sie schon im rechnen dass zum ende
des jahres auch wieder war für mittel an
den finanzminister zurückfließen selbst
dieser gesetzesänderung und das mit ihr
gegen peter ehrlich und in super
dass mit dem gegenverkehr nicht aber ich
will zu hause stehen lassen und die
beantwortung der frage können wir erst
ende des jahres machen wenn wir nämlich
wissen aus welchen töpfen geld an den
finanzminister zurückfließt
liebe frau ministerin das 230 aus dieser
debatte mitnehmen ist dass anspruch und
wirklichkeit sehr auseinander klaffen
und das gilt nicht nur auf das haus für
das haus sondern für die ganze koalition
was haben wir heute alles wieder gehört
vom chancen ministerium und das jetzt
alles viel besser wird und wie schnell
die ampel jetzt alles schön macht in
diesem land ich will nur meine kurze
zwischenbilanz zu ziehen
angekündigt waren konkrete
verbesserungen beim digital parkschule
bis märz davon sehe ich noch nichts
angekündigt waren bis ende des jahres
aktien war der eckpunkte mit den ländern
zum digital park 2 naja jetzt ist juni
unsere erfahrungen mit verhandlungen mit
den ländern lassen mich vermuten das
wird zumindest knapp angekündigt war ein
start chancen programm mit 4000 talent
schulen in diesem haushalt ist noch kein
geld aus
eingestellt ich bin sehr gespannt wie
viele schulen bis ende dieser
legislaturperiode
tatsächlich ausgestattet sind
angekündigt war die daten heute auf der
welt natur für transfer und innovation
die anzahl der fans dieser neuen agentur
hält sich wirklich sehr sehr klein ich
kenne kaum jemanden und das auch zu
recht denn die bisherigen konzeptionen
die vorliegen deuten eher darauf hin
dass man strukturen schafft die nicht
wirklich gebraucht werden weil es in den
sektionen schon diese vernetzte struktur
denn gibt die nicht auf die wirklichen
probleme einzahlen diese eigentlich
bewältigen will und deshalb gibt es
ebenso viel kritik an der daten bis hin
zum bundesfinanzminister der sagt das
geld wird erst freigeben und auch der
haushaltsausschuss sagt das geld wird
erst freigegeben wenn da mal ein
vernünftiges konzept vorliegt unterm
strich
vielleicht für ein satz zum thema stand
liebe kollegin kristen auch hier es soll
ein gesetzentwurf geben das haben jetzt
in der debatte schon öfter gehört also
wir als opposition haben die noch nicht
bekommen das sind ja ganz an ihrer seite
das wird das strukturelle veränderungen
brauchen wir kennen noch keine
vorschläge und deshalb ist die bilanz
bis jetzt eine perfekte form die die
inflation nicht ausgleicht und die
polarstern finanzieren
und das
dass ich überhaupt nicht mit dem großen
anspruch den sie als ampelkoalition an
diesem rednerpult im dieser debatte in
den letzten etappen für sich proklamiert
haben wir sind an ihrer seite dass wir
uns verbessern im bereich bildung und
forschung dass wir unser land fit machen
für die herausforderungen der zukunft
und wir freuen uns auf wenn ein auftritt
durch dieses land geht aber mit den
vorgelegten maßnahmen mit der
umsetzungsgeschwindigkeit und auch mit
diesem haushalt kann das leider nicht
gelungen
die kollegin dr lina seitz und hat das
wort die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin kollegen liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer und ich finde es besonders
schön dass hier bei der debatte des
bildungs haushalts so viele schülerinnen
und schüler auf den zuschauertribünen
sitzen
und
viele sind nur so gut wie die mittel die
zu ihrer umsetzung zur verfügung stehen
und bei all den krisen bei all den
herausforderungen auch finanzieller art
vor dem wir stehen wäre es einfach
gewesen im bereich der bildung und
forschung zu sparen aber genau das tun
wir nicht ganz im gegenteil wir erhöhen
die haushaltsmittel im einzelplan 30 und
wir stellen den ergänzungs haushalt
zusätzlich 81 millionen bereit um auch
auf ukrainische geflüchteten den zugang
in unser bildungssystem zu ermöglichen
vielleicht nehmen sie das noch mit auf
in die bilanz denn investitionen in
bildung sind investitionen in die
zukunft und innovationsfähigkeit unseres
landes und in die zukunft jedes und
jeder einzelnen dieser haushalt geht
außerdem selbstkritisch mit fehlern der
vergangenheit um nachdem das bafög in
der netz 16 jahren wäre der wenigen
sträflich vernachlässigt wurde bekommt
es nun einen zentralen stellenwert unser
ziel es wieder mehr junge menschen ins
bafög zu bekommen hürden bei der
beantragung und beim bezug abzubauen die
bedarfssätze zu erhöhen die ersten
beiden bafög novelle werden noch in
diesem jahr in kraft treten eine große
strukturelle reform verfolgt
und weil sich die kollegin schön gerade
so sehr in der wahrheit verpflichtet
gefühlt hat will ich hier einmal mit den
mythen aufräumen diesen wochen gerade
auch aus ihren reihen aber auch von den
linken immer wieder verbreitet werden
der vorwurf wir würden die jungen
menschen im rahmen der entlastungspaket
vergessen ist falsch herr oliver k zwar
gratis kreis schon gesagt aber ich
betone das gerne noch mal diese
regierung vergisst junge menschen nicht
wir reformieren dass die wir vereint
einen krisenfesten mechanismus
studierende mit nebenjob und s75
bekommen sowie alle mini mini jobber
bekommen die energiepreis pauschale von
300 euro verdoppelt den
heizkostenzuschuss wir schaffen die eeg
umlage wir führen für die nächsten drei
monate ist neun euro ticket ein wir
führen den zusätzlichen kinderbonus
eingestanden die bundesschülerkonferenz
mit 500.000 euro ein ich bitte sie das
ist doch kein vergessen wir kümmern uns
die menschen in diesem land
um menschen in ausbildung zu stärken
braucht es natürlich auch eine moderne
bildungsinfrastruktur
es freut mich besonders dass wir hier
bei der stärkung der hochschulen
wichtige signale gesetzt haben es war
uns als spd ein ausdrücklicher wunsch
den hochschulen mehr planungssicherheit
zu gewährleisten dass bis jetzt mit
diesem haushalt 20 23 durch die aussagen
zu einem zukunftsvertrag studium und
lehre gewährleistet die stiftung für
innovation in der hochschule erhält
zwölf millionen euro mehr als
ursprünglich vorgegeben damit innovative
lehr formate auch gefördert werden denn
gute digitale lehre ist mehr als die
bereitstellung von pdf-dokumenten
die kollegen zu legen mit einem volumen
von über 20 milliarden euro setzt der
vorliegende haushalt wichtige
prioritäten im bildungs und
forschungsbereich er unterstützt erneut
den fortschritt und innovation gedanken
dieser koalition ich habe es gesagt
politische ziele sind nur so gut wie die
mittel die wir zu ihrer umsetzung zur
verfügung stellen für unsere
ambitionierten vorhaben im
koalitionsvertrag
verabschieden wir mit diesem haushalt
jetzt den richtigen werkzeugkasten
vielen dank
ebenfalls für die spd fraktion hat der
kollege holger man jetzt das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren zunächst erst
mal grundsätzlich gesagt die ampel
koalition steht für das ziel die
ausgaben für forschung und entwicklung
auf 3,5 prozent des bip zu steigern
und während in europa die kommission
noch mit den mitgliedstaaten um das drei
prozent ziel falsch hat deutschland
dieses ziel auch in diesem jahr wieder
über auf der pakt für forschung und
innovation zum beispiel ist mit 75
milliarden institutioneller förderungen
3% aufwuchs solide ausgestattet wichtig
ist aber in diesem haushalt beginnen wir
diese dynamisierung auf andere bereiche
auszuweiten
für die akademien der wissenschaften ist
dies bereits gelungen und was muss man
so deutlich sagen dank der haushälter
und ihrer verhandlungen hier im
parlament gibt es eine klare maßgabe für
den zukunftsvertrag für den kommen den
haushaltsentwurf der uns ja schon bald
begegnen wird danke dafür an dieser
stelle
das sind wirklich gute signale für die
zukunft unseres landes für die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der wirtschaft und
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt für die
programm förderung sind zukünftig 9
milliarden in diesem haushalt
eingestellt und bei diesen mitteln setzt
der haushalt klar beschwerten ganz
konkret bei neuen technologien
insbesondere im feld der digitalisierung
hier wird es auch wechsel um 50% bzw 450
millionen geben in kernthemen der
informationstechnologie wie fanden
computing mikroelektronik oder
cybersicherheit betragen die auf höchste
sogar das doppelte das kann sich aus
unserer sicht sehr sehen lassen und ist
einmal kurz gesagt frau ministerin stark
watzinger hat ja herren ja subjekt
insbesondere schon darauf hingewiesen
dass zur haushalts analyse mehr gehört
als die zahlen mit dem vorjahr zu
vergleichen deswegen noch mal in einem
beispiel sie könnte eine zwischenfrage
stellen auch die medizinische programm
forschung entwickelt sich gut wenn man
sich nämlich die mühe macht harry asbeck
im haushalt mal die korona bedingten
sonderlasten raus zu rechnen dann ist
diese programmlinie seit 2009 10 um 45%
aufgewachsen das ist ein deutliches
bekenntnis zu diesem bereich und zeigt
dass wir hier schwerpunkte setzen das
muss man dann aber auch nein wir sind
überzeugt medizin und informations
technologien bieten große
zukunftschancen deswegen ganz kurz zwei
beispiele gerade eben hat das magazin
nature verkündet dass es forscherinnen
gelungen ist mit einem quantencomputer
berechnung
berechnung innerhalb von
sekundenbruchteilen zu erstellen für die
der größten supercomputer tausende von
jahren gebraucht und möchten sie jetzt
die bestellten zwischenfrage zu lassen
bitteschön
[Applaus]
form einer zwischenfrage ein kompliment
an den humor für die präsidentin so also
herr kollege wenn sie daher ist schon so
engagiert darüber sprechen dass wir in
diesem ganzen bereich biotech mehr
machen müssen was sagen sie zu der
halben milliarde für das ipad
also zum ersten ich habe über die
bereiche medizin im ganzen gesprochen
und informationstechnologien und ihnen
dargestellt dass wir deutlicher auf
hitze planen und die ministerin hat auch
die zahlen genannt das im bereich
forschung und entwicklung deutlich auf
höchste plan zum 23
der war von ihrem haushaltsentwurf ihre
ministerin überhaupt nicht veranschlagt
deswegen finde ich es eine ganz schöne
sich hier hinzustellen und zu
kritisieren dass das nicht erfolgt ist
und dazu kommen und dazu kommt dass die
mittel den vergangenen jahren gar nicht
in dem maße abgerufen worden und von
einer fraktion die sich hier regelmäßig
in die brust wirft die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse fordert steuersenkung
aber sich dann gleichzeitig hier
hinstellt und sagt wir brauchen aber
mehrausgaben
da muss ich sagen das kann auch keine
haushalt systematik sein und das ist
schon im westen sehr selbstbewusst werk
kollege ja sind
nehmen wir nochmal kurzes beispiel was
übrigens auch klar macht es müssen nicht
immer die ganz großen millionenbeträge
seien zukunft kann man zb auch im kite
projekt an der universität leipzig
erleben dort erstellt eine quali platz
um mit hunderten von indikatoren
diagnosen und behandlungsmethoden für
krebs und zwar viel genauer viel genauer
als das ein mensch und der beste
mediziner heute tun kann diese werben
für die ärzte am digitalen tumorboard
dargestellt und zugleich dokumentiert
wer weiß dass in der eu jedes jahr fast
drei millionen krebsdiagnose gestellt
werden und 200 milliarden
behandlungskosten auffallen anfallen der
hat eine ahnung davon welches potenzial
in dieser innovation steckt und wie
viele chancen bestehen das leben von
menschen zur verbesserung und vor allen
dingen zu verlängern
ich will aber auch sagen andere
forschungsmissionen müssen aus unserer
sicht in den zukünftigen haushalten noch
ausgestattet werden will man zukünftigen
herausforderungen
begegnen und diese beschrieben denn wir
wollen mehr gesellschaftliche residenz
gegen krisen entwickeln und mit der
wissenschaft die energie und mobilitäts
wende schaffen um den klimawandel
effektiv zu begegnen
dazu trotz auch mehr
ergebnisorientierung deswegen an dieser
stelle vielen dank dafür dass der
bereich transfer und die mit 25 prozent
mehr ausgestattet wurde in diesem
haushaltsentwurf zum schluss noch ein
satz der intensivste transfer von wissen
geschieht bei der ausbildung von
auszubildenden und studierenden deshalb
bin ich froh dass dieser haushalt
deutliche steigerungen bei erfolg und
dann der verhandlung der haushälter auch
bei der stiftung innovation in der lehre
enthält ich danke an dieser stelle allen
die der ampel und dem bmbf dazu
beigetragen haben und empfehle ihnen
diesen haushalt sehr gern zu erlangen
und damit schließt sich die aussprache
und wir kommen zur abstimmung des einzel
pflanzt 30 des bundesministeriums für
bildung und forschung in der ausschuss
fassung wer möchte dem einzelplan seine
zustimmung geben und ihre
vielen dank wäre es dagegen
danke sehr gibt's enthaltungen dass es
nicht der fall die koalitionsfraktionen
haben zu bestimmen die
oppositionsfraktionen waren dagegen
damit ist der 132
angenommen und ich komme zum schluss der
heutigen tagesordnung ich berufe die
nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein für morgen den dritten
juni 9 uhr
genießen sie den begonnenen abend und
die gewonnenen einsichten ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend und die
sitzung ist geschlossen